HOW TO HEAL.
THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
ANGLE.
NOW, WHATEVER YOUR POLITICAL
VIEWS, WHATEVER YOUR RACE OR
ETHNIC BACKGROUND, WHEREVER YOU
LIVE, THESE PAST THREE MONTHS
HAVE TESTED YOU IN SOME WAY.
THE CORONAVIRUS DEATHS.
LOCKDOWNS, MASSIVE JOB LOSSES,
EDUCATION DISRUPTION,
LONELINESS, DEPRESSION, AND
THEN, JUST WHEN WE WERE TURNING
THE CORNER, PROTESTS, UNREST,
VIOLENCE.
THE DEATH OF AN UNARMED BLACK
MAN.
IT ALL SPELLED OUT
COAST-TO-COAST AFTER THAT
SENSELESS KILLING OF GEORGE
FLOYD.
NOW, MANY OF YOU WONDER IF IT’S
EVEN FIXABLE AT THIS POINT.
I’VE BEEN HEARING FROM YOU.
AND GIVEN HOW MUCH ANGER FLASHES
ON THE SCREEN EVERY DAY AND
EVERY NIGHT AND SO MANY USING A
TRAGIC DEATH AS PERMISSION TO
LOOT AND EVEN ASSAULT INNOCENT
BUSINESS OWNERS AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT, THE HONEST
FEELING OF -- ITS SADNESS AND
RIGHTEOUS ANGER OVER FLOYD’S
DEATH THAT COULD BE CHANNELED
INTO POSITIVE DIALOGUE, IT’S
JUST OVERSHADOWED BY DESTRUCTION
AND CHAOS.
ANTIFA AND THEIR ALLIES, THEY’RE
ON A MISSION.
AND IT AIN’T ABOUT JUSTICE.
IT’S NOT ABOUT GEORGE FLOYD.
THEY WANT TO ABOLISH OUR RIGHTS
UNDER THE CONSTITUTION AND THEY
WANT TO REWRITE OUR HISTORY.
THEY WANT US TO HATE OUR COUNTRY
LIKE THEY HATE OUR COUNTRY.
TODAY, TO CLEAR MY HEAD, WHAT I
DID AS I WENT ON A BIKE RIDE.
I KNOW THAT SOUNDS FRIVOLOUS AT
A TIME LIKE THIS BUT I HAD TO
CLEAR MY HEAD, IT’S ONE OF THOSE
DAYS.
I TOOK MY OLDEST SON AROUND THE
NORTH SIDE OF THE NATIONAL MALL.
BUT WHAT I SAW WHEN I WAS THERE
MADE ME WANT TO CRY.
I’VE LIVED HERE FOR 30 YEARS AND
THE ONLY TIME BEFORE TODAY THAT
I SAW NATIONAL GUARD TROOPS
AROUND OUR NATIONAL MONUMENT WAS
AFTER 9/11.
THERE THEY WERE, DOZENS OF THEM,
GUARDING THE LINCOLN MEMORIAL,
THE KOREAN WAR MEMORIAL, THE
VIETNAM MEMORIAL AND THE
WORLD WAR II MEMORIAL.
A FEW DAYS EARLIER THOUGH THE
WORLD WAR II MEMORIAL HAD BEEN
VANDALIZED WITH SPRAY PAINT.
SO THE EXTREMIST RADICALS,
NOTHING, NOT EVEN A PLACE OF
HONOR SUCH AS THIS IS SACRED.
WELL, ONCE AGAIN, THEY MISREAD
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THESE SITES AND WHAT THEY
REPRESENT, WHOM THEY HONOR OUR
SACRED TO US.
SO WHAT DID WE DO?
WELL, MY SON AND I WE STOPPED
AND SAID A SHORT PRAYER, AND
THEN I PROCEEDED TO THANK EVERY
MEMBER OF THE GUARD THAT WE CAME
UPON.
AND I TOLD EACH AND EVERY ONE
HOW MUCH WE APPRECIATED THEM.
IT WAS A CROSS-SECTION OF
AMERICA, AFRICAN-AMERICAN MEN
AND WOMEN SERVING ALONGSIDE
WHITE MEN AND WOMEN, MOSTLY
YOUNG.
THEY WERE KEEPING WATCH AS
RUNNERS, TOURISTS STREAMED BY,
SOME PROTESTERS, BUT IT WAS
QUIET.
PRESUMABLY THERE ARE MORE
WORRIED ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS AT
NIGHT TONIGHT IN WASHINGTON, AND
WE HOPE FOR THE BEST.
WHEN THOSE BRAVE SPRAY PAINT
MILITANTS COME OUT TO DESECRATE
AND DESTROY.
OF COURSE, NONE OF THEM KNOW
WHAT REAL SACRIFICE IS, FOR IF
THEY DID, THEY’D BE DOING
SOMETHING POSITIVE WITH THEIR
LIVES.
THE WAY FORWARD FOR THE REST OF
US THOUGH REQUIRES THAT WE GET
BACK TO BASICS.
WE DON’T NEED A NEW NORMAL.
WE JUST NEED NORMAL.
BECAUSE NORMAL AMERICANS WANT A
FAIR AND JUST SOCIETY WHERE THE
RULE OF LAW APPLIES EQUALLY TO
ALL PEOPLE REGARDLESS OF RACE.
NORMAL AMERICANS ARE DISGUSTED
BY THE KILLING OF GEORGE FLOYD.
NORMAL AMERICANS THINK THE
CURRENT SITUATION IS SO OUT OF
CONTROL THAT THE U.S. MILITARY
NEEDS TO BE CALLED IN TO BRING
ORDER TO THE STREETS.
CHECK OUT THIS NEW MORNING
CONSULT PAUL SHOWING 58% SUPPORT
CALLING IN THE TROOPS TO AID
STATE AND LOCAL POLICE.
INCLUDING NEARLY HALF OF THE
DEMOCRATS.
THE SAME PARTY THAT’S BEEN
PROMISING AFRICAN-AMERICANS
BETTER LIVES FOR DECADES.
OUR FIRST AFRICAN-AMERICAN
PRESIDENT WAS PROPELLED INTO
OFFICE NOT ONCE BUT TWICE WITH
THE MAJORITY OF WHITE SUPPORT.
YET WHEN IT COMES TO DELIVERING
ACTUAL RESULTS, INCLUDING FOR
AFRICAN-AMERICANS, DESPITE WHAT
YOU HEAR IN THE MEDIA, DESPITE
EVERYTHING YOU HEARD JUST TODAY
IN THE MEDIA, DONALD TRUMP HAS
DONE BETTER THAN ANYONE.
BEFORE THE CORONAVIRUS, MOST
JOBS CREATED WENT TO WOMEN AND
MINORITIES.
7 MILLION.
IN TOTAL, MOST OF THOSE WOMEN
AND MINORITIES.
BLACK AMERICANS SAW THEIR LOWEST
UNEMPLOYMENT NUMBERS EVER.
INCREASED HOME OWNERSHIP, SCHOOL
CHOICE, CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM.
CREATION OF OPPORTUNITIES OWN.
THOSE WEREN’T HASHTAGS OR
SLOGANS.
THOSE ARE REAL POLICIES THAT
PEOPLE WORKED REALLY HARD ON TO
DELIVER REAL RESULTS.
JOE BIDEN WAS IN THE SENATE FOR,
WHAT, 30 YEARS?
HE WAS VP FOR ATRIUM AND ALL HE
CAN COME UP WITH NOW ARE
SYMBOLIC GESTURES, SLOGANS,
HASHTAGS, PROFESSIONS OF EMPATHY
EMPATHY.
THEY’RE FINE, BUT THEY DON’T
CREATE JOBS.
THEY DO NOT CREATE OPPORTUNITY.
BUT THEY CAN CREATE THE ILLUSION
OF CARING.
>> I WON’T TRAFFIC IN FEAR AND
DIVISION.
I WON’T FAN THE FLAMES OF HATE.
I WILL SEEK TO HEAL THE RACIAL
WOUNDS THAT I’M LONG PLAGUED OUR
COUNTRY.
THIS JOB IS NOT ABOUT ME.
IT’S ABOUT YOU.
IT’S ABOUT US.
BEFORE WE
>> Laura: HE’S BEEN SAYING THE
SAME THING FOR DECADES AND HE’S
DONE NOTHING.
AND IF HE AND OBAMA KNEW HOW TO
DELIVER ALL THAT THAT HE JUST
SAID, IT WOULD HAVE DELIVERED
WHAT HE SAID BEFORE THEIR TWO
TERMS IN OFFICE -- DURING THEIR
TWO FORMS IN OFFICE.
I UNDERSTAND FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE, TRUMP MAY BE ROUGH
AROUND THE EDGES.
THE SOMETIME DON’T LIKE HIS TONE
OR HIS TWEETS OR HIS BRAVADO, IT
MIGHT TURN YOU OFF AT TIMES, BUT
HE’S WORKED HARDER, WITH BETTER
RESULTS THAN ANY POLITICIAN I
KNOW, I’VE EVER MET, TO BRING
PROSPERITY TO ALL PEOPLE AND
ESPECIALLY ONCE PROSPERITY FOR
THE AFRICAN-AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
REMEMBER, IT’S THE WORKING CLASS
PEOPLE AT THE CORE OF HIS
AMERICA-FIRST MOVEMENT.
THE RICH ELITES, THEY WANT --
ALL THOSE PEOPLE FROM
WALL STREET IN HOLLYWOOD.
THEY VOTED FOR HILLARY AND
THEY’RE GOING TO VOTE FOR BIDEN.
AND BY THE WAY, THOSE OF THE
SAME PEOPLE, MANY OF THEM
NEVER-TRUMP, WHO THOUGHT
OUTSOURCING JOBS TO CHINA WAS A
GRAND IDEA.
AND THEY’RE THE SAME ONES WHO
SOUGHT TO KEEP FOREIGN WORKERS
FLOODING INTO THE COUNTRY,
INCLUDING ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS,
ALL OF THEM ARE FOR JOE BIDEN.
THE AMERICA-FIRST MOVEMENT, YOU
KNOW, IT’S NEVER GOING TO HAVE A
LOT OF CELEBRITIES.
BUT IT HAS SOMETHING BETTER.
IT HAS POLICIES THAT LEAD TO
PROSPERITY FOR MORE PEOPLE.
AND THE MORE PROSPEROUS YOU ARE,
MOST OF THE TIME, THE LESS
RESENTFUL YOU WILL BE IN THE
MORE PEACE YOU WILL HAVE.
WE WANT THAT FOR ALL PEOPLE.
AND WHEN BIDEN SUPPORTERS SAY
THEY JUST THINK ABOUT IT, THEY
SAY THEY WANT TO DEFUND OR EVEN
ABOLISH THE POLICE, ASK YOURSELF
FOR A MOMENT, WHO’S THAT REALLY
GOING TO HELP?
WHO WILL BE THE VICTIMS OF THOSE
CRIMES THAT GO ON PROSECUTED?
WORKING CLASS AND DISADVANTAGED
PEOPLE.
THAT’S WHO.
BECAUSE THE RICH PEOPLE, THE
ONES THAT ARE GOING TO VOTE FOR
BIDEN, THEY CAN HIRE THEIR OWN
SECURITY.
BUT EVERYBODY ELSE IS JUST GOING
TO END UP MORE VULNERABLE AND
LESS SAFE.
THAT’S HOW THAT WILL ROLL.
WE’VE SEEN EVIDENCE OF THIS, BY
THE WAY, DURING THE PAST WEEK
WHEN COPS WERE NOWHERE TO BE
FOUND.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> Laura: PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
DEMONSTRATED THAT HE WILL WORK
WITH ANYONE OF ANY PARTY IN ANY
STATE, ANY TIME, TO HELP MORE
PEOPLE GET OUT OF POVERTY.
AND THAT INCLUDES, BY THE WAY,
REFORMING INSTITUTIONS TO ENSURE
THAT EVERYONE GETS A FAIR SHOT.
BUT THAT PROCESS DOESN’T REQUIRE
BURNING IT ALL DOWN OR CREATING
A PERPETUAL GRIEVANCE CULTURE
LIKE THE ONE THAT EXISTS ON
COLLEGE CAMPUSES.
THAT WILL JUST SET EVERYBODY
BACK AT A TIME WHEN NORMAL